bref les briques commencèrent à moteur
est très bien aux plateformes on est
très content de te voir et ben moi aussi
je suis très content je vois alors ce
soir au programme des lauriers un gros
des bribes de ce qui s'est passé
vendredi dans touche pas à mon peu
spécial années 2000 avec un cyril
hanouna niveau ligue des champions une
régie niveau ligue 2 des chroniqueurs
mito et surtout vous allez assister à la
naissance de l'animal la dégradation
l'animal alors vendredi le prime a duré
sept heures non six heures de danse
ouais ouais ça se voit que danser alors
si vous avez beaucoup danse en duo
aurait remarqué alors ce que j'ai adoré
c'est selon à partenaires que vous aviez
vous n'aviez pas la même fougue et ça
c'est un tout petit peu vu je vous
décerne le laurier du danseur qui
n'arrive pas à cacher ses préférences
avec ses partenaires david et le monde
par exemple khalifa luna c'est très
caliente
[Musique]
avec mia frye et vos corps sont
tellement proches que vous ne faites
plus qu'un
et en revanche quand vous dansez avec
daniel moreau vous garder une distance
de sécurité de promettre
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi je vais vous dire pourquoi j'ai
fait ça j'avais peur que ça dérape
non mais je me connais avec daniel je me
connais comment cela mais je vous dis
j'ai franchement très égale danger de
très galles sécurité giuly j'ai pas
voulu
j'ai pas voulu alors qu'il rentrait non
ça m'a rappelé un peu christian clavier
thierry l'a remis dans le père noël est
une ordure envoyée souvenez vous de là
on a la photo c'était fait j'étais un
petit peu loin mais non mais parce que
je vous dis j'avais peur de déraper
approche trop d'elle quand on s'approche
trop du feu au risque de se brûler c'est
une très belle phrase alors le jour où
touche pas à mon poste s'arrêtera en
2030 les gens retiendront deux choses 1
que c'était la seule émission il y avait
une djette qu'il n'en sait jamais de
disques oui et 2 que c'était la seule
émission où il y avait autant de
problèmes de régis que téléspectateurs
alors au vendredi c'était tellement
énorme truc c'était la nouvelle grande
passera quoi je pensais la race track
est de retour et en fait je décerne
cette spéciale années 2000 le laurier de
l'émission qui a eu deux mille problèmes
de régie
[Rires]
des années 2000 se dire on y va bien sûr
on y va arrêter partie touche pas à mon
sens
[Applaudissements]
ses parents
[Musique]
je comprends rien odinga ce soit
n'importe quoi la séquence que sont ils
devenus vous aviez prévu de faire de
belles mises en scène pour faire entrer
des anciens du loft mais malheureusement
personne n'avait l'air au courant qu'est
ce qu'ils sont devenus
est-ce qu'ils travaillent tous les deux
dans une compagnie d'assurances est-ce
qu'il prépare un single tous les deux
oui ce qu'ils sont toujours dans le loft
en train de dormir profondeur ce qu'on a
là on a la preuve en images regardez ce
qu'ils font actuellement regardé et on
les a voilà c'est juste un voilà merci
merci merci
[Musique]
c'est déception forcément quand vous
demandez des enseignes musique on voit
votre tête cou n'allait plus du tout
confiance
rappelé de billy crawford a lancé j'ai
pas peur de vous dire que vous êtes dans
mon top 3 deux animateurs préférés non
si je vous assure avec son héros mais
jusqu'où et vincent cerrutti 27-3 parce
que pourquoi vous êtes un peu comme le
ce que les américains appellent un
entertainer et vendredi vous avez donné
une véritable leçon à tous vos
concurrents
je vous remets le laurier de l'animateur
qui est écoeurant tellement il s'étouffe
quel qu avec le groupe las ketchup ou
prouvé que l'espagnol n'a aucun secret
pont en fête
bongiorno vous chanter des trucs et
lettres me connaît inquiète de voir
trouver parfois un petit peu seul rap et
du bouddha d'assaut
c'est bon c'est beau le gouda frais en
fin de repas surtout vous êtes au sol ni
matters qui demande à danser sur de la
musique accéléré oui ça sert à rien mais
c'est marrant quand même
[Applaudissements]
vous avez fait ça toute la soirée
à
[Musique]
aulas va-t-il apparaître là qui fait si
j'ai quitté alors dans le prime des
années 2000 bien sûr parler de
secretstory bien sûr alors vous avez
joué un jeu il fallait deviner les
secrets des chroniqueurs bon vu les
secrets ça aurait pu s'appeler secret'
pourri parce qu'il ya deux chroniqueurs
qui pourraient avoir le secret je suis
un gros mytho
je leur dessert les lauriers de ceux qui
ont des secrets aussi mito que dans
secretstory président georges jouer un
président de la république du libéria
donc amené avec lui et la seule photo
que tu as trouvé si tu passes derrière
nous tu te fous de ma gueule ou quoi
jusque là vous avez des nouvelles de
nuit là d'où je suis en train d'en
prendre également montré très bien ce
rapport prédit le meilleur ami
imaginaire de jour jouer à c'est au tour
de daniel moreau de sortir son mythe all
et en cause en ce moment dans sa chambre
tommy haas assez bien bien passé il
reste d'ailleurs un souvenir une photo
qui va tomber et au toit
[Rires]
on est très proche
la meilleure photo alors les photos de
gildan elles sont extraordinaires et ça
m'a rappelé l d'afida turner spatz à vue
la semaine dernière il a publié une
photo hommage à karl lagerfeld comme
s'ils avaient des inconnus regarder où
elle est n est pas du tout alors là le
connaître mieux le connaître
voilà la plus passé c'était son petit
paraît que c'est son pote alors il est
temps de revenir à ce qui a marqué tous
les téléspectateurs
c'est la fin c'est vous receviez mia
frye un ancien juré de popstars alors
mia frye soit l'abus à la bûche soit le
un coup de foudre en direct pour vous ce
qui est possible parce que cette baisse
soit elle va être chroniqueuse année
prochaine
alors je la comprends parce qu'elle a vu
que doc gynéco été payée si pour dormir
pour qu'elle se dit pourquoi pas moi
alors j'ai jamais vu une invitée
complimenter autant un animateur aussi
un petit peu mal à l'aise
elle est un petit peu quand même mais
bon grâce à mary série on a assisté à la
naissance d'un nouveau personnage qui
est immédiatement rentré dans la légende
de la télévision française
voici le laurier dessus qui est passé de
baba à l'animal
quand on est près de signer un truc
quand on est à moins de 5 ans il vous
est phénoménal déjà vous de marquer and
lights au plus fashion
[Musique]
on vous a pas demandé vous de faire les
oscars ce qui est génial access et qu'il
est ou non de la sensualité la
sensualité
[Musique]
il y eu
[Applaudissements]
c'est un petit peu puisque vous avez
quand même été à la préfecture pour
changer votre identité regardez-moi ça
si si je vous assure